[INAUDIBLE]
is a very interesting developer
community--
I'm glad somebody has asked
this question I think--
This is where the
magic happens--
This is primarily a question and
answer show, so if any of
you out there would like
to ask questions--
DANNY HERMES: Hi, everybody,
Welcome to our most recent
edition of the Content
API for Shopping
community, office hours.
This week it's more of
a fireside chat.
As you know, I'm Danny Hermes,
developer programs engineer on
the shopping team.
I have a special guest here
with me today, Andrew
Lamonica, one of the lead
engineers at Zazzle.
Maybe the lead engineer at
Zazzle And also, my new
teammate, Burcu Dogan--
I believe is how it's
pronounced.
BURCU DOGAN: Yes,
you are right.
And I will be replacing
Danny shortly.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
And we'll talk a bit about that
at the end, after Andrew
does his demo.
And for the last introduction,
I'll let
Amanda introduce herself.
AMANDA SURYA: I'm Amanda
Surya, and I lead the
developer relations for
our commerce products.
And thanks for joining us, and
thank you, Andrew, for coming
to our office today
to talk to us.
So I guess we can get started
with talking about Zazzle.
Do you want to tell us what
Zazzle is, Andrew?
ANDREW LAMONICA:
So Zazzle is--
Zazzle.com is a custom
products marketplace.
We're based here in
the Bay Area.
People can take pictures or
graphics that they've created
and upload them to Zazzle and
create mugs, or t-shirts, or
iPhone5 cases, or
postage stamps.
And then you just buy them
and we send them to you.
One of the neat features of
Zazzle is that it's also a
marketplace.
So if you have some good content
that you want to share
with the rest the world and
make royalties on, you can
post it for sale and when
somebody buys it, we'll pay
you a royalty and handle all the
logistics of shipping and
manufacturing and customer
support.
AMANDA SURYA: That
sounds awesome.
ANDREW LAMONICA: That's the
run down of Zazzle.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
ANDREW LAMONICA: I could
give a quick--
AMANDA SURYA: Yeah, we'd
love to see it.
ANDREW LAMONICA: A quick
overview of the site.
You can see here many of the
things that you can create.
This is actually only a
small subset of them.
And, you know, shirts and
stickers and water bottles and
all sorts of fun stuff.
You can also do searches for
content that has been provided
by other people.
I just did a search for
Google Doodles here.
Google is one of the companies
that actually
provides content to Zazzle.
We have companies,
in addition to
individuals, who upload content.
So you can buy some Google
Doodles on a t-shirt, or a
sticker, or a mug,
or something.
DANNY HERMES: I kind of want
to buy the Sesame Street
Google Doodle.
AMANDA SURYA: I know, right.
DANNY HERMES: I had
no idea I could.
AMANDA SURYA: I love that.
ANDREW LAMONICA: It's probably
on there somewhere.
Actually, this is not a super
good example, but some
products that are provided
are even customizable.
So you can add extra
text to them.
I think I totally spelled
that wrong, but
it might still work.
No, it did not.
DANNY HERMES: What
did you type in?
ANDREW LAMONICA: I tried to type
Mickey Mouse Shirt, but--
DANNY HERMES: Gotcha, gotcha.
ANDREW LAMONICA: That should
be pretty safe.
AMANDA SURYA: So how many
different types of products
that you can print?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Actually, I'm
an engineer at Zazzle, so
unfortunately I'm not up on the
latest count, but I would
guess about 100.
It becomes a much larger number
if you count individual
SKUs of shirts.
You can buy smalls, or green,
or the silver version, or
something like that.
So you can also customize
products and buy them so you
can put your name on it or
something like that.
I'm totally not that familiar
with my own website.
DANNY HERMES: That's OK.
ANDREW LAMONICA: So, the reason
I'm here today is
Zazzle actually uses the
Google Shopping API.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
You guys obviously have a pretty
sweet website that
you're showing.
And you have, from what I know
in the outside world, a pretty
loyal following and also some
other casual users that make
your user base pretty big.
So, as Andrew said, we invited
him here for a reason.
And it wasn't just to sell
Zazzle, we wanted to talk to
him about engineering.
So, Andrew, if you'd like, could
you give us maybe a bit
about what the history is with
you guys sending product data
to Google, whether
it's through the
Content API or for others?
And also, your use of the API,
with all the data you guys
have from your large user base,
how that gets used, and
how this has helped
you or hurt you?
Whatever you want
to lay on us.
ANDREW LAMONICA: So, as I
mentioned before, Google has a
marketplace.
And it's a very low
bar to entry.
So people can just upload a
picture, they don't have to
pay any money, they don't
have to do too much
just to get up there.
Which means we consequently have
millions and millions and
millions of products that
we then want to
provide people to buy.
And so we have a lot of
channels to get that
information out there.
And Google Shopping offers us
a couple of good channels.
One of which is it integrates
pretty well with AdWords and
with the Google Affiliate
Network, which is display
advertising.
And it also powers the
Google Shopping sites
in the various countries.
I forgot to mention earlier
that Zazzle is in 17
countries, so we have lots
of content and lots
of different languages.
DANNY HERMES: I've never
been to 17 countries.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Well,
me either.
AMANDA SURYA: Some day, Danny.
DANNY HERMES: Some day.
ANDREW LAMONICA: So when we
first started out with Google
Shopping, we didn't contact
Google or anything, we just
signed up and we just
started uploading--
AMANDA SURYA: Feeds.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah, feeds.
gzipped XML files with the
maximum number of products--
which I think is, that's
changed over the years.
DANNY HERMES: I think 20 megs
is the max now, it's not the
number of products.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Oh really?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
ANDREW LAMONICA: So anyway, we
started with that and that
worked for some applications.
It was kind of limited though
in several ways.
And one of the things early on
that was a problem was, we had
lots of different accounts
because we had different
stores in different countries.
And that was fixed when Google
contacted us-- or we contacted
them or something-- about
multi-client accounts, which
is what we're doing now.
We basically have one of
those for each country.
Not one multi-client account,
but one sub-account, which is
really helpful because, as
I'll mention later, when
debugging it's nice to have
everything in one place.
Recently though--
maybe a year, year and a half
ago-- we switched to the
Content for Shopping API which
actually solved a lot of
important problems for us
over just uploading
giant gzipped XML files.
Probably the biggest one was
that our content was sort of
perpetually out of date.
We were doing one big upload
of every file every day.
And that meant that the minimum
turnaround time--
well actually, there could be
the maximum turnaround time
would be 24 hours.
So you could upload a product
and then something about that
product changed, and Google
wouldn't know about it for
some time after that.
AMANDA SURYA: And as a
marketplace, you had a lot of
price changes, I'm sure.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yes, so another
thing I didn't mention
about Zazzle is that when you
post a product for sale, you
get to set the price.
And you're even offered the
opportunity to change that
price, along with just about
everything else about the
product except for the physical
picture itself.
So you can change the keywords,
or the title, or the
description, and all of that
content needed to be given to
Google as soon as possible.
Especially the price, because
when the price changes, it's
against Google's terms of use
if you're showing the wrong
price for a product
on your website.
Or showing a different price
from what you saw
upload in the feeds.
DANNY HERMES: And you'd probably
rather not have that
anyway, right?
You're
ANDREW LAMONICA: No.
It's also a bad experience
for the customer.
They think they're paying--
they click on a link that says
$25 and it's $22, and they're
scratching their heads.
DANNY HERMES: They don't
know who to be mad at.
ANDREW LAMONICA: And they
don't know, did
this product change?
Am I not in the right place?
I wanted the one that was $25.
So Content for Shopping solved
that problem immediately.
Overnight, when we started
uploading changes to the
products as they came
in, you no longer
have the price problem.
DANNY HERMES: Do you find a
lot of the updates you're
sending fall into the express
pipeline where you're only
changing availability, price,
and things like that, to where
they'll make it into
the index faster?
ANDREW LAMONICA: So
actually, yes.
I don't have the numbers on that
but a lot of the changes
that we really care about are
the high availability ones.
Another feature of Zazzle is,
since we're a marketplace, we
don't actually look at every
product that everybody uploads
all the time.
And sometimes after a day or so,
someone will notice that a
product is a copyright
violation, or for some reason
it's bad quality and it needs
to be taken down, or it's
miscategorized or mislabeled.
I think somebody tried to
sell an iPhone case
as an iPhone once.
They just made it look like it
was an iPhone that was--
and they set the price
and everything.
It's very complicated,
but we need to take
those products down.
And those we can tell Google
about it right away as well.
I'm assuming delete is high
availability, but if it's not,
we also set it as
out of stock.
Those two things should take
it out of Google quickly.
Removal of content, and also the
other thing was, it's very
nice for a site like Zazzle
that deals with a lot of
trending content, to
be able to get
things up there quickly.
You don't want the "Don't Tase
Me, Bro" t-shirt to come out
two weeks after the video,
because by then no one will
even know what you're
talking about.
DANNY HERMES: Assuming everyone
watching does know.
I do, but I don't know about
everyone on the internet.
ANDREW LAMONICA: I'm not
even sure I remember.
I'm pretty sure there was some
video related to somebody
being tased, and it was funny
for about two weeks.
But, yes, so that kind
of content needs
to be uploaded quickly.
And the Content for Shopping API
gives us the opportunity
to do that, whereas the big
feed files really didn't.
Especially because one of the
most time consuming parts of
uploading the big feed was
picking products to upload.
Also another thing that this
saved us, I mentioned that it
was very time consuming to pick
what products to upload,
it was also very hardware
intensive to pull all of that
data out of our data store
in one big batch
and then upload it.
So the Content for Shopping API
lets us do only a subset.
And I actually-- before I came
here today-- looked at the
numbers and I believe that,
even though we're getting
faster turnaround time and
changing up our feed more
frequently, we are sending a
tenth as much data as we would
with the big feed files.
AMANDA SURYA: That's
pretty awesome.
ANDREW LAMONICA: So we got a lot
of advantages and we saved
resources on probably both sides
of that transaction.
DANNY HERMES: Network
resources if
nothing else, right?
Even if you don't think
about hardware.
ANDREW LAMONICA:
It's actually--
one drawback that I've not
encountered recently but I
encountered early on, is that
it actually does take more
bandwidth to send the Content
for Shopping request than it
does to send a giant gzipped
file, but it's so much less
data that you end up saving
in the long run.
DANNY HERMES: So you're talking
in total length of the
connection or in
something else?
ANDREW LAMONICA:
Just in bytes.
DANNY HERMES: Really?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: Wow!
The payloads are big
because of the spec
and things like that.
ANDREW LAMONICA: There's extra
metadata and there's also--
I suspect there's a way to fix
this, but I haven't found a
good way to upload
gzipped content.
So even though I'm doing
batch requests--
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
It took me a really long
time to get it working.
It's some header iteration that
you have to get perfect.
But if you get the headers
right it's
actually not too bad.
We can maybe start a post on
the forum and it's your
question and I'll post an
answer with the header.
Somebody actually asked
something about this a few
months ago.
And we--
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah,
I saw that.
And I tried to reproduce his
solution it was unsuccessful.
DANNY HERMES: So maybe we'll
do a deeper down into it.
ANDREW LAMONICA: That
would be good.
Great.
I'm not sure that the bandwidth
expense is the
biggest thing right now, but
it's definitely nice to be
able to contract those.
And I assume you can send larger
batches if they're
gzipped as well, right?
DANNY HERMES: Yup.
One meg is a hard cap no matter
what's in the payload.
It's not like unzipped one meg
or anything like that.
For those who aren't familiar,
batch requests are limited.
You can put as many products
as you want so long as the
payload doesn't exceed
one megabyte in size.
Anyhow, sorry to interrupt.
ANDREW LAMONICA: I briefly
mentioned the one drawback--
DANNY HERMES: Feel free.
Lay into us.
That's all right.
Let's hear it.
ANDREW LAMONICA: There's a
couple other small drawbacks
that I put in my notes here.
Actually, these are mostly
related to complexity.
The Content for Shopping API is
a more complex system and
will require a little bit more
concentration from the
developers than just creating
a giant file and FTPing it.
The things on my list include
authentication, which is
certainly more complicated.
We are still using ClientAuth,
and I understand
that is going away.
So we're going to have to make
that transition to OAuth soon.
But even ClientAuth, if you
don't use a library from
Google, can be some
extra work.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Parsing the initial response
back, and getting the correct
token, and things like that.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Another thing
is that it's not ideal for
massive changes.
I think this is mentioned on
the forum, maybe a couple
times, people saying I
want to change every
product in my feed.
All 100,000, 200,000, 500,000,
and I'm getting timeouts, or
slow down, or errors.
And that's a problem that we
have had very rarely because
we've optimized the selection
process to minimize the number
of changes made.
But if we ever had a big change
like discontinuing a
product, or changing the prices
on everything, or
something like that, I could
see where that might take
several days to actually upload
rather than the file.
DANNY HERMES: I did the math
once and it came out to like
four hours.
On a million products--
ANDREW LAMONICA: Really?
DANNY HERMES: But--
ANDREW LAMONICA: That's
pretty good.
DANNY HERMES: But six million
we just made it to a day, so
maybe I should redo the math.
ANDREW LAMONICA: It might just
be my programming ability.
I haven't quite made it.
I'm multi-threading but maybe
there's some more I could do
there to get the requests
in there faster.
Although it is nice to just not
have to worry about it to
a certain extent.
Once you have the system in
place to update products as
they change, people can make
business decisions to change
products all the time, and those
changes will trickle
into Google.
So I'm not sure that I would
even do a big file upload if I
had a massive amount
of changes to do.
I might just let things be out
of date for however many hours
it took to get it there.
The biggest technical
challenge--
it wasn't really a technical
challenge-- but the biggest
complexity in this system over
the file uploads has got to be
the 30 day time limit.
DANNY HERMES: I'll let
you explain this, but
this is true for both.
ANDREW LAMONICA: It is true.
So it's actually, in both cases,
any product that is not
updated within 30
days is ejected
from Google's Shopping.
DANNY HERMES: Expired.
ANDREW LAMONICA:
Expired, yeah.
So with feed files it's very
easy to think about this,
because if you upload a feed
file every 30 days, or less
than every 30 days, then
you know that every
product will be safe.
In fact you can kind of--
although I'm sure that there's
a little bit of variance here--
you can kind of just
assume that whenever you
uploaded the file, every
product will expire 30
days from that time.
DANNY HERMES: Unless
you explicitly set
an expiration date.
ANDREW LAMONICA: That's true.
You can set a shorter
expiration date.
With the Content for Shopping
API you don't want to upload
every product, every day,
because that would sort of
defeat the purpose.
DANNY HERMES: And
waste resources.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yes.
So you need to keep track
of when you have
updated which products.
At least that's the way we
solved that problem.
Whenever a product is updated,
for whatever reason, either
because it was selected to be a
product given to Google, or
because it was removed, or
because it's a brand new
product, or something
like that.
Or something changed about it,
like the price, we upload that
product to Google, and we keep
track of the timestamp of when
we uploaded it.
We also--
and I believe right
now we're using 25
days just to be safe--
any product it has not been
uploaded in the last 25 days
is uploaded again.
We have this constant running.
And that's why it's 10%.
It would probably be a lot
smaller if it weren't for the
products being refreshed
periodically.
I understand the need for the
refresh, but that's certainly
something that you have to think
about when you decide to
do Content for Shopping
API versus feeds.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
BURCU DOGAN: Could you please
give us a little bit more
detail about your existing
infrastructure?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Sure.
Right now what we do is--
We already have an existing
infrastructure on Zazzle to
notify various interested
modules
about changes to products.
So I hooked into that
infrastructure.
And it's not like in line with
the website, but it's just a
little bit offline
from the website.
So when a product changes, or is
deleted, or something like
that happens, this module is
notified of that change.
And I batch up those changes
into Google API batch requests
and send them across.
And then I get some
feedback on those.
And I actually do track the
feedback, both in log files
and I also think I keep one
result for each product, which
helps me know when there are
products that are being
rejected for some reason
or something else.
I can decide what to do
with those later.
I can either remove them, or I
can fix them, or I can notify
content review that this
is a bad product, or
something like that.
DANNY HERMES: So what you're
saying is, for developers out
there who aren't doing it, you
should be logging at least the
most recent response from the
API so you can go back in and
play doctor, and figure
out what went wrong.
Why that product got sick.
Is that what you're saying?
ANDREW LAMONICA: I am.
Yes.
You can also--
AMANDA SURYA: Pro
tip [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: Pro
tip from a pro.
In my opinion.
ANDREW LAMONICA: You can do what
probably most people do
because Google has such great
tools online to see your
requests and to see
what has failed.
You can use that as
a double check.
But it's probably good--
especially if you have a very
large catalog, more products
than can be uploaded to Google
under your agreement--
It's a good idea to check to
see what's happening with
those products because it's
certainly not worthwhile to
send the same product that's
going to fail again, and
again, and again.
You want to take that out, or
take that whole class of
products out.
And this is probably going to
become more important with the
AdWords transition because the
AdWords rules are much more
strict about what you can
and cannot include.
At least from what I've noticed,
we have a higher
percentage of--
DANNY HERMES: Disapprovals.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yes,
disapprovals in AdWords than
we ever had with just Content
for Shopping.
So Slowly we will work through
those and say, well you can't
do this, you can't do that,
you can't say this word.
I know, originally, I had some
people who are putting all
capital titles in there
and other things like.
DANNY HERMES: What's
the rule in AdWords
about exclamation points?
You only get one.
Isn't there something
like this?
ANDREW LAMONICA: You only get
one exclamation point?
DANNY HERMES: Somebody on the
AdWords DevRel team was
telling me about this
a couple weeks ago.
ANDREW LAMONICA: That's
a good thing to know.
I'll probably have to deal
with that one, too.
Some people are very excited
about their t-shirts.
The API dashboard--
which I guess you're going
to show that later--
DANNY HERMES: We'll be talking
about it in a sec.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Is
really good for
finding systemic problems.
DANNY HERMES: That's the
word I was thinking of.
Maybe I just psychically
put it in your head.
ANDREW LAMONICA: And
I have used that.
I have actually encountered
problems before, where I just
looked at the dashboard
and I knew there
was something wrong.
I had a problem a few months ago
where we were sending too
many requests.
I was confident that the number
that was being sent
every day was higher
than it should be.
And it turned out that there was
a problem with the way we
were deleting products, where
we were deleting them but we
weren't remembering that
we were deleting them.
So we tried to delete it again,
and we tried to delete
it again, and we ended
up with a--
DANNY HERMES: Bunch of 400s.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah,
basically.
Google would send back the
response saying product not
found and I saw that
right in the thing.
That that number was
also going up.
And that seemed kind of like
a very good clue to
what was going on.
DANNY HERMES: Awesome.
Awesome use case.
AMANDA SURYA: Do you 100% use
Content API for Shopping now
or do something still go
back to the feeds?
ANDREW LAMONICA: We haven't
uploaded significant feed
files since we switched over
to the Content for API.
I do occasionally upload a feed
file to check things.
I have some test products
that I upload.
There's some sort of
undocumented components, like
what happens to text tags that
aren't in the official spec.
And I want to make sure that
those are doing what I think
they're doing.
There's also--
Google Affiliate Network has a
lot of custom tags, and it's
nice to be able to, in addition
to sending those
Content for Shopping, but it's
nice to be able to upload some
test products offline, not
through the main system.
And then ask them, did
you get the products.
AMANDA SURYA: So mainly
for testing.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah.
I haven't used it for sending
day-to-day products, and
there's a good reason
for that.
The expiration model on those
is kind of confusing.
Because when you upload
a file with a lot
of products it appears--
you guys can correct me
if I'm wrong on this--
It appears that Google still
treats that as individual
update requests over a period
of time after you've
uploaded the files.
Maybe it's an hour, or maybe
it's just 10 minutes, maybe
it's five minutes, but during
that time if you do some other
update request in the Content
for Shopping API, you could
totally lose that.
So you--
DANNY HERMES: Race condition.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah,
basically it's a race condition.
That's a programmer's term
for basically two things
happening at once.
So when those two things happen
once, the outcome is
unclear and it's better
to not send the same--
if you are going to separate it,
you need to send different
products, so you're sure that
they don't overlap and don't
enter into any of these
race conditions.
You were going to ask
another question.
DANNY HERMES: I was?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah, but I
kind of waylaid you there.
DANNY HERMES: No.
I was going to comment.
You were saying sometimes you
use feeds to test stuff out.
The interactive demo can also be
a great tool to test stuff
out if you're sending individual
products or
relatively small payloads that
you can type by hand.
But if you'd rather use--
ANDREW LAMONICA: I actually
have done that.
And I actually do both because
the syntax is subtly different
between the feeds and the
Content for Shopping API.
There are some different
namespaces and a couple of
things like that.
I also use the really great
structured content API demo
page to test things.
Especially when I run into some
problem that is a mystery
to me, like a single request
failing for reasons unknown.
I'll put that put that
in there or I'll
type it from hand.
And then what I'll do
is I'll just remove
stuff until it works.
And then I know what--
DANNY HERMES: Binary search
for dummies, right?
ANDREW LAMONICA: That's a
terrible way to debug, but
it's very effective
on obscure bugs.
I would recommend everybody
try that page.
It's a little bit weird with
the multi-client accounts.
You have to be careful about the
ID number because as soon
as you log in it resets
the ID number
back to the main account.
Which is inevitably--
DANNY HERMES: The ID of the
authenticated user.
ANDREW LAMONICA: And that is
never the account that you
want to upload products to.
DANNY HERMES: You're not allowed
to anyway, right?
ANDREW LAMONICA: That's
caught me a few times.
I submit and it's like access
denied or something.
I'm like, I don't understand
what's going on here, but then
I realize that it just
change the number.
Until you guys get an
opportunity to fix this, you
should probably log in and
then type the number in.
DANNY HERMES: Yup.
And for those who are unfamiliar
with the debug tool
he was talking about or the demo
tool he's talking about
right now, I'm going to be
posting a link in the actual
description on YouTube.
Just wait until this video
actually ends up in the final
published mode and
it'll be there.
Do you have anything else you'd
like to add before I
start to demo?
ANDREW LAMONICA: No.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
So I've got a very short
demo for everyone.
Andrew was talking about
the debug tool.
A tool which is nice for
systemic errors.
And for the typical user who
doesn't have an MCA, this
change doesn't affect you.
But for people who are managing
lots of accounts,
this is a change which can
be pretty helpful.
So I've got my sub
account here.
I'm logged in as an
owner of the MCA.
So you see here, here's
the parent MCA.
Actually let me zoom a bit.
So you see here is the parent
MCA name, and then my sub
account name, Dangoog, I'm Dan,
I work for Goog, right.
So I click the API Dashboard
tab and I
go see my API Dashboard.
I have Flash disabled
by default, so
let me enable that.
And you see here, by default,
my dashboard tells
me I have 21 errors.
And that actually is conditional
on a setting that
these are requests
that I have made.
But if we were to go to the
user setting, we would see
that other than the owner of
the MCA there's also some
owners or users affiliated just
with the sub account who
could also make requests.
So, prior to this, I wouldn't
have actually been able to see
these requests and all.
These are erroneous requests
I've made as the parent
account on behalf of
the child account.
And before this feature launched
I could only see
those requests within
the dashboard
of the parent account.
But now I can see them
on the dashboard
for the child account.
But what's more, I can also
say all requests targeting
this account.
So instead of just the requests
that I've made, I can
also see other erroneous
requests.
So when I load up this map--
these are all from
earlier today.
Sorry I didn't have time
to get the data in.
The future just launched
today.
But we see this number--
let me zoom even
more if I can.
No, I'm at max zoom.
For those who can't see, if it's
not a good enough zoom on
the picture, there are now 41
errors instead of the 21.
So me and one of
my teammates--
actually our technical
writer for our team--
we did a bit of demo with some
errors to actually preload
this dashboard.
And so she actually made
20 more errors.
And so we actually see, if
we want to see all errors
affecting his account, we can
see the ones I made but we can
also see the ones
everyone made.
So that's the feature that
launched, and I'm happy to
announce it.
We will be sure to update some
of the documentation in the
Merchant Center and maybe even
have a blog post for those who
are interested in having
this in written form.
So before we go to the
moderator queue--
I haven't had a chance to look
at it yet, but Amanda is going
to read it to us--
I'd like to outline some changes
around this team and
this particular biweekly
hang out.
So as you may have heard from
Burcu, or if some of you are
just general Google Developers
Live fans, you may have
noticed that I've been doing a
lot of App Engine Hangouts
with the App Engine team.
And I also did one with
the YouTube team on
behalf of App Engine.
And I'm going to moving full
time over to App Engine.
And Burcu is going to be taking
my place full-time.
And she's going to be working
closer with the ads folks than
I was, which is obviously going
to benefit everyone.
But she's also going to be
physically closer to the API
engineering team, which I think
is also going to be a
huge benefit to everyone.
So I'm sad to go, but I'm
excited for new things.
And before we jump on the
moderator, I'll give Burcu a
chance to talk a bit about
herself, and tell you guys--
BURCU DOGAN: This is actually
my second week at Google.
DANNY HERMES: Third.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah, third.
I've been working as a software
engineer for six
years and I worked on very
diverse fields, from telecoms,
to mobile, from maps, to
gamification, and this is
going to be a great challenge
for me as well.
So I'm very glad to be here.
I hope that developer community
will grow because
there are a lot of things
coming interesting.
And I'm taking Danny's
place, but--
DANNY HERMES: So I think she's
probably more than capable.
I think--
BURCU DOGAN: What would you
like to add, Danny?
DANNY HERMES: That
she will probably
embarrass me as an engineer.
She's phenomenal.
You guys are being left
in great hands.
BURCU DOGAN: Thank you, Danny.
AMANDA SURYA: And with the team
changes, we might also
change the structure
of this show.
And that's still being
worked out.
Stay tuned for updates.
DANNY HERMES: Usually we
announce the next one.
We're not sure when the
next one will be.
We'll certainly still do them,
but every two weeks, the
frequency may change.
And I guess with that, I'll let
Amanda go to the moderator.
What are we looking at?
AMANDA SURYA: So, we have
a couple of questions.
The first question, if products
are submitted via the
Content API are the same
requirements for showing tax
and shipping enforced
as with feeds?
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Good question.
Andrew wants to answer, but
I'll answer this one.
You can think of feeds files and
the Content API as sort of
doors to the same house.
The data ends up in the same
place and, as a result, has
the same requirements.
So if you're not going to
include tax and shipping,
either with feeds files or the
API, it has to be an account
level setting.
And that's always the same.
So the spec is not any different
for what actually
needs to be in your data.
Like I said, doors to
the same house.
Once it gets in, it goes through
the same sort of
validation, though the
synchronicity of this
validation is very different.
And in cases like the express
pipeline for the Content API
which allows changes to make it
into Google Search Index in
a matter of minutes rather than
a matter of hours, the
Content API is clearly
superior.
What's next question?
AMANDA SURYA: All Right.
So this is more for Zazzle.
So this person--
frustrated but hopeful,
that's his user name--
he's curious about how
Zazzle uses the API.
Especially around filtering
junk content, or queries.
How do you make sure that--
I guess you're also marketplace,
right--
so how do you make sure that
the content that you're
uploading, the products that
you're uploading to Google is
following the terms
of service.
ANDREW LAMONICA: This is
actually probably one of the
most complicated parts of the
feed program that we employee.
Especially because Google is
not the only place that we
send product data too, and
everybody has slightly
different rules.
There's some kind of basic
rules that are built into
Zazzle already that we follow.
For example, Zazzle users are
allowed to give their product
a maturity rating, and we use
that to make sure that we
don't send adults only products
or something like
that to Google.
We also have our own content
review team that works on
making sure the copyright
things are followed.
BURCU DOGAN: They are doing
this by hand or--
ANDREW LAMONICA: They have a
whole workflow by themselves.
They have scripts, and they do
it by hand, and they have some
automated suggestions,
and things like that.
But I hooked into that system as
well to make sure that I'm
not selling anything that
we think is not good.
But then I also just
have some rules.
Google frowns on all
capital titles, so
I've just remove that.
Yes I also frown on those.
I have not used to the
new API for finding--
DANNY HERMES: Data
quality feed?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Data quality
issues, but I've use the
website sort of informally to
go on there and look and see
what's been rejected
programmatically and then I
just apply those rules to
my selection process.
I believe I mentioned earlier
that one of the most time and
resource consuming parts is
selecting the products.
One of the reasons is because
we need to check those
products for potential problems
like all capital
titles, or bad words, or too
short, the title could be too
short, description could be
too long, or it could have
some kind of weird XML in it
that maybe Google doesn't want
to display on their site.
so it's a pretty manually
implemented process.
And it's different for
every feed consumer.
AMANDA SURYA: And how about
on the Google side, Danny?
Any insight?
DANNY HERMES: As for what?
AMANDA SURYA: There's
a lot of filtering.
BURCU DOGAN: Data quality
and relations.
AMANDA SURYA: Data quality,
signals--
DANNY HERMES: So what
in particular are
you hoping I'll share?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Please give
us a list of words that we
cannot use.
AMANDA SURYA: Not that.
DANNY HERMES: As far as things
like that, we have
some tools in place.
So the great thing--
I say this a lot.
I kind of feel like a broken
record-- but the great thing
about the API is that we
have two stages of
validation for the data.
One is the initial stage to make
it into the house, but
then from there you
have to make it
further into the house.
So the first stage of validation
is like, the
payload you send is valid XML,
or all the required attributes
are sent, things like this.
But there are more complex
things that
happen after the fact.
So we have two stages.
First stage, we'll just say
immediate rejection.
You didn't send a required
element, you didn't provide a
title that was long enough, you
didn't actually send XML,
right, or something that our
parsers understand as XML.
But then there's a second stage
which will check for
other things like bad words, or
certain things that maybe
we don't want to display,
or websites they
don't actually work.
For your case, since you
guys are hosting all
content, is the case?
So when you're checking quality
data for users, they
upload content, but after
they've uploaded, you host it.
So you don't have the
same sort of issue.
You're not going to check
against yourself for the
quality of a webpage,
but these are issues
that we deal with.
Whether it's API or not,
either way we're
dealing with this.
Is that what you were
hoping I would say?
AMANDA SURYA: Well that's pretty
much it in terms of the
questions in the moderator.
DANNY HERMES: So I think
we'll wrap up.
Amanda, I think maybe you had a
public service announcement
that you wanted to make.
AMANDA SURYA: Yes.
Our team is hiring.
If you're interested--
ANDREW LAMONICA: So Is ours.
DANNY HERMES: No, seriously.
AMANDA SURYA: If you're
interested in joining in our
team, you can check out
our job openings at
developers.Google.com/jobs.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
What about Zazzle's
job openings?
ANDREW LAMONICA: I bet it's
slash jobs, but I'm going to
be kind of dumb--
DANNY HERMES: Let me
see, I'll race you.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yup.
That is a really ugly
page, but--
DANNY HERMES: Whatever,
it'll work.
ANDREW LAMONICA:
Zazzle.com/jobs.
DANNY HERMES: There we go.
AMANDA SURYA: Thank you so much,
Andrew for joining us.
DANNY HERMES: Yes, it was
great to have you.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Thank you And,
we'll miss you, Danny.
AMANDA SURYA: He's
not going far.
Thank you everybody.
BURCU DOGAN: Thank you.
AMANDA SURYA: Bye-bye.